[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
tuesday july 19th i'm zoe thomas for the
wall street journal
today marks the start of christy's fifth
annual art and tech summit where the
auction house brings together experts to
discuss the role of emerging technology
in the art market
but christie's isn't just talking about
tech's role in helping collectors buy
and sell more art on monday the world's
largest auction house announced it's
also launching a new venture capital arm
to invest in tech startups
that's despite traditional vcs pulling
back from riskier sounding tech ideas as
interest in backing some tech startups
is falling
plus the recent drop in crypto values
has raised questions about the long-term
popularity of blockchain-based art like
non-fungible tokens or nfts
so why is christie's taking this leap
now and what does it tell us about the
future of art and tech
joining us to discuss that is our art
market reporter kelly crowe
hi kelly thanks for being here thanks
for having me
so let's start with what kind of tech
companies christie's is planning on
putting its money behind
yeah so they really want to look for
companies that
are exploring questions and problems
that have long be deviled sort of the
art world but using new technology right
so they're interested in
companies that may be looking at ways to
ease the process for people to go on and
get a digital wallet and sort of spend
crypto or spend their real money on
digital things or even just sort of
look at ideas about authenticity
disputes ideas of tracking and
cataloging art as it changes owners over
time there's tons of just inefficient
ways that the art market and our world
has long tried to pay attention to how
art moves around the planet and they're
really going to be looking for companies
that are
trying to solve some of those riddles
using technology
so this isn't really about investing in
artists who are using technology or in
the kinds of tech that could be used to
build technology this is about the
collectors you know buying and selling
right
well they're interested in
infrastructure as well so you know if
you have a bunch of assets in one
particular type of cryptocurrency for
instance right they want you to be able
to go on any platform any site and just
click and buy an artwork that you like
or you know buy and spend things using
that without having to sort of have the
clunky
process of trying to move currencies
from one to the other akin to when we go
on to a website to buy an airplane
flight right the site doesn't really
care for using dollars or euros or
whatever it just kind of seamlessly sort
of converts that currency and makes it
easy for us to spend however we want to
spend it and right now that doesn't
really happen very easily in the digital
space and certainly using these new
currencies the nft
the non-fungible token world is still
sort of clunky in terms of those
transactional things have they invested
in any companies like this yet
yeah so far they've come forward as
saying that they have invested seed
capital in a company called layer zero
labs um it's a vancouver-based company
that does sort of precisely that what
it's trying to do is make it easier for
people
to spend their money across different
blockchain platforms without having to
you know spend a lot of money on what
they call
you know gas fees or these conversion
fees
okay so making it easier for people to
spend their money i mean of course
christie's as an auction house so we
would assume they'd want people to come
in and spend their money i wonder though
if you can kind of take us back a little
bit and paint a bit of a picture of how
much tech and art has been overlapping
over the last couple of years
well it's a huge departure for the
auction houses i mean these companies
christie's and sotheby's have been
around for longer than our country right
and for most of that time like the
lion's share of that time these houses
have done deals over handshakes
and sort of clubby back rooms and
lunches and i mean so much art changes
hand with a handshake and with a
contract that's signed in some cases
very little
technology at all but the pandemic
really proved to be a wake-up call
because once they couldn't get people
into the room to physically raise a
paddle right it really came home that
they needed to develop their series of
online sales they needed to be able to
put art in front of people digitally
they started looking around for
companies that could maybe create
holograms of fragile or oversized
artworks that would be tricky to ship
around the world i mean you can't really
create an edgar degas you know sculpture
amid the pandemic and send it to san
francisco and hong kong like it just
wasn't happening and so they really
started i would say out of desperation
to look for what kind of tech could
solve their own problems and then what
they found is that there's a huge
audience and a demand for that so i
would say they're kind of i mean all the
houses are a little bit johnny come
lately to this but there really are
seizing the opportunity now to catch up
i mean how much money are these auction
houses or are christie's particularly
making off of you know art that is
really much more reliant on tech
and uh you know maybe the kind of nft
boom that we've seen over the last few
years
i mean when it comes to nfts it's a
really brutal time right now to be
honest i mean christie's really got the
ball rolling when it sold that digital
collage by the artist people for 69
million dollars that really was like an
earthquake shock right throughout not
only the art world but the nft space
that collectors were willing to spend in
cryptocurrency investors were willing to
spend big bucks right for
a digital receipt attached to some
pixels i mean it really did sort of
engineer a huge revolution the problem
is that now you know crypto prices are
so volatile and crazy that the demand
for nfts sort of at the level that
christie's likes to sell them has really
shriveled for the moment so you know
last year they sold 93 million dollars
worth of nfts so far during the first
half of this year christie's has only
sold like nearly five million dollars
worth of bit of teas
so then what does this tell us i guess
long term about the art market and its
reliance or use of tech that christie's
is making this kind of investment i
think it's really fascinating because
it's really fun when you see an old
company that's
set in its ways trying to evolve right
like we need to you know adapt to
both market constraints and just sort of
the ebb and flow of technology and some
companies have long been resistant to
that and the auction houses were
resistant to that galleries were but
again because of the pandemic everyone
has had to rethink the model galleries
are hosting you know artist q as online
now and
and offering you you know virtual views
of everything they're taking to art
fairs some of this is just a natural way
in which we're moving our lives
digitally in lots of ways and so of
course we're going to move our
collecting and our buying and selling of
art online and i think that
christie's move is certainly a signal
that it doesn't want to be left out in
the cold and if new technologies are
going to end up being game changers for
all the houses they just want to make
sure you know they get a bid in early on
to be a part of it i like that get a bid
in for the auction houses all right
that's our reporter kelly crow thanks so
much for joining us kelly thanks a lot
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing
if you want more tech stories check out
our website wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
you